so another prime generating formula it's
actually the most important one of all
it's called the prime number theorem so
let me write it out I think it deserves
being written out really important
result in mathematics it's so important
that you can refer to it by its TLA you
can refer to it by its three-letter
acronym just call it P NT people know
what PN T is the prime number theorem
it's that important and the prime number
theorem is about how many Prime's are go
less than a number n right so how many
Prime's are there less than a billion
something like that
and so the formula says that the number
of primes less than n well the symbol
for that is PI of n now don't be
confused this pie is not 3.14 it's
nothing to do with pi we use the symbol
for something else so it's P 4 prime so
number of primes less than n and this is
approximately n divided by natural log
of n a couple of things to say because
some of you might won't be familiar with
that natural log of n some of you will
but for the ones who aren't familiar
I'll try and quickly show you it's just
a function you could call it you know
it's just a thing any number you pick up
number any number like n can be written
this way as a e to the power X e is
another constant it's 2 points I never
remember what it is 7 1 8 something
something something so any number can be
written that way
it's 2.718 to the power of something and
the log of n is this bit it's X it's the
power so that's what log is if I plot
log of X it looks like this it's
actually this is actually growing but it
grows really really slowly
I think the log of a billion is 21 so
you put in a big number and you're
actually getting a very small number out
it's always getting bigger it's actually
tending to infinity one more thing to
say this twiddle
is a new symbol to you till doubt or
twiddles as I like to call it it's a new
symbol what it means is if you divide
those two things so I'm going to divide
them like that you divide those two
things that's tending to 1 as n gets
bigger that's what it means slightly
technical you can say approximately
equal to of you happy with that but that
has a proper meaning so what it's told
us is tells us how many on average it
gives an approximation at least how many
Prime's we can expect less than a number
a billion 10 billion a googol but we can
then get some results from that that
means that the proportion of prime
numbers is well if we divide by n the
proportion of primes less than n is 1
over log n so if we're talking a billion
I said the log of a billion was 21 so
the proportion of primes is 121 it's
like 5% 5% of numbers less than a
billion or prime you can call that
probability if you want if I picked a
number at random what's the probability
that it's going to be a prime number
it's 5% what does it mean it does mean
that the prime numbers are getting rarer
more spaced out as the numbers get
bigger so this proportion is getting
smaller the gaps we can write the gaps
as well
the average gap between Prime's is now
equal to log of n so if n was a billion
again they stick with that it turns out
the average gap between the primes is 21
as sum of sum of bigger gaps some have
smaller gaps some of twin primes but the
average gap is 21 let me give you a
number and you give me all the stairs
I'll give you a number give me the give
me the state of the nation for the first
5 and a half billion numbers five and a
half billion five and a half billion is
this so a billion has nine zero so this
is five and a half billion we're going
to take the log of that the natural log
we got twenty two twenty two point four
between two point four what do you know
no so I know that the proportion of
primes less than five and a half billion
is one over twenty two again it's just
like well let's see is it four percent
let's see if we can do it
yes about 4 percent of numbers less than
five and a half billion are prime the
average gap is about twenty two point
four trade to twenty four to twenty
three cents a lot of information and
then one more thing one more thing to we
can learn from this a prime number
formula the nth prime twiddles or is
approximately n lots of log n so you can
might you might see where this comes
from if the average gap is log n then
and you want to know the nth prime you
can multiply by n you add the gaps all
together the nth prime is approximately
n log n which means five and half
billion the the five billion 500 million
the litter prime is it's actually gets a
better result the bigger the number is
so it helps you find but it isn't it is
an approximation rather than those
formulas of prime number formula giving
ones one more thing I wanted to say
about this this average gap we've
discovered with log n I said it was an
average so sometimes you get bigger than
that sometimes you get twin prime you
know you make an average of it you get
log n the gaps do have bounds on them
you can't go as big as you like
there's actually a little it's called
Bertrand's postulate and it says if you
pick any number to pick the number n he
said that there will be a prime that is
bigger than n and smaller than 2n so you
can't you can't have a gap that is too
big
there's a little rhyme for this the
rhyme is Chevy Seth said it and I'll say
it again there's always applying between
N and 2n and if you put n as a prime
instead let's take it it's the enth
prime then the next prime you're looking
for has to be sandwiched between prime
and two times the prime let's pick a
prime Prime's the last version to do it
in unless what pick a prime 1111 is fine
right so let's have 11 always telling
you is that you're guaranteed to have a
prime between 11 and 22 which is true so
the gaps can't get too big for Prime's
over 100 you can do better than 2 that
can actually shrink down to one point
two so that stack you see quite a narrow
gap so that just means that the primes
can't have very very very long gaps
between them so they're quite regular
Prime's are always turning up the fairly
regular and there's infinitely many of
them but they like weeds
they're always popping up you can't get
rid of them there's another prime you
don't go for too long without another
prime popping up surely when we get up
into the soul of the grams numbers of
the world those weeds become a bit more
sparse they become spaced out but
proportionately
compared to the size of numbers that
you're using the proportion is actually
very very tiny in absolute terms though
really spaced out but as a proportion to
these huge numbers we're talking about
they're close this this prime number
formula is actually the easy version of
the prime number formula there's more
sophisticated versions of this is they
look the same but they've added on extra
terms and so you can see that the error
is sort of zigzagging around zero ish